[Music]
then I'll start with you I'm curious you
get this iconic phone call the call that
everybody wants every guy that grew up
loving Batman wants will you be Batman
what was your response the phone rings
and they're offering you the chance to
be better yeah I mean honestly the first
thing I thought was like well that's not
you know I'm I was thinking of them
doing the sort of the origin story the
new Batman he comes out he you know he
discovers himself he he even wants to
avenge his parents death he fights the
superevil and I thought that's not me
I'm not that that Batman you know and
and Zak was like no no this guy he's
like he's older and he's really tough
but he's broken down and he's on the
edge of moral bankruptcy that's
hilarious that you start the
conversation by saying no I'm not Batman
you know which is what Bruce Wayne would
say on that same phone cause I was
already in character I would know that
they call if I got that call I'd be yes
yes yes from the beginning but you had
your trepidations and then what what is
obvious seeing the film is that it's the
Frank Miller version of Batman and
there's a lot of what got me really
excited was it was that Dark Knight
Returns version of of the character
which is that kind of you know being
seriously that he's more broken down
he's kind of like a brawl or a
heavyweight boxer in the 12th round you
know guy who's torn up and that is kind
of wit's end and I thought there was
something kind of cool and punchy and
fun about about that Frank Miller
version yeah and and and I'm curious
kids now I get to ask you the same
question Henry if this is the second
time you've done Superman outfit but the
first time you got the call that you
could play Superman what was your
reaction well the first time I got the
call I actually missed it
I was I was playing World of Warcraft at
the time and I had my priorities
straight
wait a minute you were at home it's not
like you weren't home you were home but
you were playing a little Warcraft and
the phone rings and you're like I'll get
that later okay yeah yeah absolutely
I'll get that later and I was playing it
was an important part of a particular
dungeon that I was going through
and it's cool now that I'm Superman yeah
and and then I looked across at last
moment I saw Zack Snyder's name on the
phone so I grabbed the phone and then
missed it right and so I called him back
immediately and said I'm really sorry I
was saving someone's life I missed your
call which is what I do all the time and
yeah then he gave me the news so you
were forget yeah you were forgiven I was
yeah that's good
you